okay we got shit-faced and sugar tits
okay guys in my pocket I have some
broken lizard trivia questions whoever
answers these questions correctly is
gonna win a walk-on part in the next
movie
exciting right okay here we go chick
face your first the first question is a
Super Troopers question have you seen
Super Troopers yeah you do great I'm
gonna do great all right
between Kevin and Steve which of us
would you rather
don't shout out the answer
which of us would you rather chip face I
want a mustache ride knowing this guy
right here
by the way face that answer is
correct
one-nothing face alright sugar tits
you're not buddy your question is a
Beerfest question have you seen beer
fests you do great man you can do great
shirt it's between Kevin and Steve which
of us would you let you it's a little
different which of us would you let you
test before you answer this question I
would just like to say to all of you
that this game was way better with
chicks good game with chicks a lot of
fun with girls very good game of chicks
okay but we make do okay you sugar tits
what's it gonna be